-Good evening! I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
The Colorado Supreme Court
ruled yesterday
that former President Trump
is ineligible
to run again for president,
while the Florida Supreme Court
ruled he already won.
[ Laughter ]
Supreme Court Chief Justice
John Roberts spoke yesterday
at the memorial service
for Justice Sandra Day O'Connor
and said "she was so successful
that the barriers she broke down
are almost unthinkable today,"
adding,
"but we're working on it."
[ Laughter ]
At a rally last night in Iowa,
former President Trump
told the crowd that immigrants
are "destroying the blood
of our country."
Pretty ironic thing
to say in a state
that only exists
to produce corn syrup.
[ Laughter ]
After facing comparisons
to Adolf Hitler,
former President Trump
said yesterday
that immigrants are destroying
the blood of our country
and added, "They said,
'oh, Hitler said that
in a much different way,'"
but you've already lost
the argument if you have to say,
"Guys, I wasn't quoting Hitler.
I was paraphrasing him!"
[ Laughter ]
That's right. After facing
comparisons to Adolf Hitler,
Trump said that immigrants
are destroying the blood
of our country and added,
"I've never read 'Mein Kampf,'"
yet no one thought you had.
I'd be surprised if you read
"The Art of the Deal."
[ Laughter ]
At a conservative conference
yesterday,
Republican Senator Ted Cruz
told the crowd
that the left is unhappy
and added,
"if you were a liberal woman
and you had to sleep
with those weenies,
you'd be pissed too."
Well, joke's on you, Ted,
because liberal women
sleep with each other...
[ Laughter ]
...dude.
The scooter rental company Bird
has filed for bankruptcy.
Apparently, it's not profitable
to charge people
10 bucks to chuck
your scooters into the river.
[ Laughter ]
A 90-year-old woman
recently graduated
from the University of North
Texas with a master's degree.
At least I hope
that's what they meant
when they said she passed.
[ Audience groaning ]
[ Mouthing silently ]
[ Laughter ]
Minnesota yesterday
unveiled its new state flag,
which features
a light blue background
with a white north star.
The flag was designed
by Minnesota artist Lucas.
[ Laughter ]
Good. Lucas.
A New Jersey police officer
was arrested yesterday
for allegedly stealing drugs
from an evidence room.
Police confiscated the drugs,
but he's pretty sure
he knows how to get them back.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, the CDC estimated
this week
that roughly 20% of
recent coronavirus infections
have been caused by the newly
discovered subvariant JN.1,
or as most Americans
are calling it, "allergies."
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
We are off and running.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We got a great show
for you tonight.
You know him from
"Marriage Story," "Girls,"
"House of Gucci," "Star Wars"
and as an excellent "SNL" host.
His latest, "Ferrari,"
is in theaters on Christmas Day.
Our friend Adam Driver is back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We got Adam Driver
in the building.
And he's
one of my favorite stand ups.
His book, "Misfit: Growing Up
Awkward in the '80s,"
is out now,
and his new stand up special,
"Born on Third Base,"
premieres tomorrow on MAX.
Gary Gulman
will be joining us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, I had a very --
I had a very big night
personally last night.
For the first time, I went --
I saw Billy Joel in concert
at MSG.
Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'd heard great things,
and one of the greatest concerts
I've ever been to.
I would love to go again.
But guess what, guys.
I don't need to go again
'cause I took a cellphone video.
[ Laughter ]
Pretty smart.
During "Piano Man,"
I think I was the only guy
who thought about it.
Took like a 45-second video
of the middle of "Piano Man."
And now, I mean, I feel like
when people find out
I have this...
bidding war.
[ Laughter ]
Can you imagine?
45 seconds.
Not even a full verse.
Just a weird middle.
Weird in point.
Weird out point.
Like, from
"real estate novelist"
to "sing us" and then out.
[ Laughter ]
From so far away.
From so far away,
that halfway through it,
there's a weird zoom...
that just, like,
really stretches the pixels.
This video couldn't
exonerate Billy Joel
if he was suspected of a crime.
[ Laughter ]
If the cops were like, "We like
Joel for the bank heist,"
and I was like,
"It couldn't have been him.
He was at
Madison Square Garden,"
and showed it to them,
they'd be like,
"Which one is he?"
And I'd be like,
"The guy at the piano."
And they'd say,
"What's the piano?"
The best --
I had the best time.
Scream singing.
Scream singing
"We Didn't Start the Fire."
Maybe got 10 words right.
[ Laughter ]
Confidently scr-- I said
"Bridge on the River Kwai"
five times before I was right.
[ Laughter ]
Time of my life.
So if you got a free night
and you're in New York City,
go to Big Apple Circus.
[ Laughter ]
Look, you know,
Billy Joel is great.
I don't have to sell Billy Joel.
He's a legend.
I went to Big Apple Surface --
Circus. Excuse me.
You guys, I've been
out and about this week.
[ Laughter ]
Big Apple Circus on Sunday.
Billy Joel last night.
I'm a man about town.
Big Apple Circus is so good.
At one point -- And, again,
I am not connected to them
financially in any way.
[ Laughter ]
At one point,
a performer lies on their back
and puts their feet up,
and they put --
she has a table on her feet
and she just spins the table.
And until that moment, I never
thought I wanted to see that.
[ Laughter ]
I never in my life
walked into a room,
saw a table and was like,
"Oh, what I wouldn't give
for someone to flip
that upside down
and just like helicopter it."
Kicks it up. Catch it.
It was the greatest night
of my life.
To quote Billy Joel...
♪ Trouble in the Suez ♪
[ Laughter ]
You know, I talked a long time
about the circus on Monday...
and then I read one of
the comments on YouTube.
And you know what somebody said?
"I guess a guest
must have dropped out."
[ Laughter ]
What's that?
Oh, Adam Driver showed up?
Okay, great.
I can stop
with all this bull[bleep].
[ Laughs ]
You guys, moving on, Billy Joel!
He's a legend. Moving on.